Maligayang pagbabalik sa quantum computing sa praktika. Ang episode na ito ay magtutuon sa una at madalas na pinaka-
mapaghamong hakbang sa pagtukoy ng isang quantum program. Ang pag-map ng isang pangkalahatang problema sa isang circuit na maaaring tumakbo sa isang quantum
computer. Inilalarawan ng hakbang na ito kung paano ang isang user na nagsisimula sa isang ibinigay na computational
problema ay maaaring isalin ito para maunawaan ng isang quantum computer.
Sa mga nakaraang aralin ng seryeng ito, mga aralin dalawa at tatlo, tinalakay natin na ang mapping stage ay ang unang hakbang
sa apat sa loob ng Qiskit patterns framework. Mula sa mga araling ito, maaaring matandaan mo na ang aming layunin ay isalin
o muling isulat ang isang computational problem sa isang cost function o isang expectation value
na maaari nating suriin gamit ang isang quantum computer.
Sa aralin tatlo, tinalakay natin ang isang kongkretong halimbawa sa max cut, isang problema
na computationally mahirap at karaniwan sa combinatorial optimization.
Sa halimbawang iyon, dumaan tayo sa ilang hakbang para baguhin ang paunang graph sa isang quantum native problem. Binago
natin ang problema ng paghahanap ng maximum na bilang ng mga cut sa graph sa isang cost function. pagkatapos ay muling isinulat ang cost
function bilang isang Hamiltonian at naghanda ng isang trial quantum state na ang ground state
ay katumbas ng max cut. Sa wakas, nagtayo tayo ng isang quantum circuit na kumakatawan sa trial quantum state ng
interes at pagkatapos ay nagdagdag ng mga tiyak na gate para hayaang mag-evolve ang estado sa paglipas ng panahon. Ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga hakbang na ito ang tinatawag nating
mapping. At sa mataas na antas, ang pamamaraan ay pangkalahatan sa maraming ibang mga aplikasyon tulad ng quantum chemistry
at quantum simulation. Ngayon, walang makakaiwas sa katotohanan na ang mapping ay maaaring maging mahirap. Wala itong
one-size-fits-all na estratehiya para sa bawat solong problema, kaya maaari itong maging nakakatakot. Ngayon, ibibigay ko ang
ilang representatibong mga halimbawa ng iba't ibang mga problema at ilalarawan kung paano sila na-map sa bawat kaso. Mabilis ko
itong bubuuin kung ano ang natutunan natin tungkol sa mga problema sa graph tulad ng mga ginamit sa Max Cut at gagugol ng natitira sa lektura sa
kung paano i-map ang mga problemang lumalabas sa kalikasan tulad ng mga problema sa molecular structure sa biology, electronic
structure problems sa chemistry at simulation ng quantum field theories sa high energy physics.
Ngunit bago natin gastusin ang karamihan ng ating oras sa episode na ito na naghahanap ng mga halimbawang problema mula sa literatura, gusto kong bigyan ka
ng mataas na antas na pagtingin sa mga pangunahing bagay na gusto nating makamit at isaalang-alang kapag nag-ma-map kami ng isang problema. Mayroon
ilang mga bagay na dapat isaalang-alang para sa anumang uri ng computational problem na kailangang isalain sa isang quantum circuit.
Una, maaaring kailanganin mong pasimplehin ang problema para maging feasible ito. Ito ay isang karaniwang bagay sa karamihan ng siyentipikong
mga disiplina. Hindi ito natatangi sa quantum computing. Kung narinig mo na ang ekspresyon na assume a
spherical cow, ito ay isang pahiwatig sa katotohanang madalas na mahirap ilarawan ang isang sistema nang eksakto tulad ng hitsura nito. Ngunit
sa halip, maaari tayong gumawa ng mga makatuwirang simplipikasyon na maaari pa ring humantong sa mga kapaki-pakinabang na solusyon.
Ang ilang mga halimbawa kung paano natin ito magagawa sa quantum computing ay ang limitahan ang laki o ang circuit depth sa pamamagitan ng pagpili ng isang
hardware efficient ansatz o pag-truncate ng mga kumplikadong time evolutions o pagpapabaya
ng mga Hamiltonian terms na kaunti ang naiambag sa huling enerhiya ng isang quantum state.
Ang susunod na punto na gusto kong gawin ay kailangan mong mag-isip tungkol sa pagsulat ng problema sa paraang mauunawaan ng isang quantum computer.
Madalas na nangangailangan ito ng pagtanong sa tatlong tanong na ito. Isa, ano ang kumakatawan sa ating mga qubit
sa modelong ito? Dalawa, tuluy-tuloy ba ang ating problema? Dahil ang mga quantum computer ay digital, kakailanganin mong
makahanap ng paraan para i-discretize ang problema. At tatlo, sa wakas, ang topology ng problema ba ay naaayon sa topology ng
hardware? Kung oo, iyon ay mahusay. Ngunit kung hindi, maaaring kailangan nating ipatupad ang ilang mga trick para gumana ito. Kaya tugunan natin
ang unang tanong na ito. Ano ang sa palagay ko ay nasa puso ng lahat ng mga kahirapan sa pag-unawa sa mapping lalo na bilang isang
bagong konsepto. Ano ang maaaring katawanin ng isang qubit?
Ang mga qubit ay maaaring gamitin para kumatawan ng maraming bagay. Ang una at pinakasimple sa aking palagay ay isang node sa isang graph. Ang mga graph ay
ginagamit para ipakita ang connectivity at maraming iba't ibang uri ng mga problemang matematikal. At ang mga node ay isang pangunahing elemento na kumakatawan sa isang punto
o entity sa loob ng isang network. Depende sa kung ano ang kinakatawan ng buong network, maaaring iyon ay isang lungsod, isang tao o isang
ferromagnet sa isang lattice. Ang mga qubit ay maaari ring gamitin para kumatawan ng mga boson at fermion. Bagaman mag-iingat ako dito
na ang isang solong qubit ay hindi eksaktong katumbas ng isang boson o isang fermion. Ito ay kaunti
mas kumplikado kaysa roon at tatalakayin ko ito sa lalong madaling panahon, ngunit sa pangkalahatan, ang isang chain ng mga spin na sumusunod sa ilang statistics ay
isang bagay na madaling isalain sa isang qubit architecture.
Ngayon, pumapasok tayo sa mga halimbawang kaunti na mas kumplikado. Para sa mga modelong ito, hindi na makatwiran
na magsalita sa mga tuntunin ng isang solong qubit.
Sa halip, kailangan natin ng mga grupo ng mga ito para bumuo ng isang bagay na pisikal. Halimbawa, isang
grupo ng mga qubit na ipinapakita dito sa isang heavy hexagonal topology ay maaaring gamitin para kumatawan ng mga geometrical na lokasyon ng amino
acids o polymer chains. Isa pang halimbawa ay ang simulation ng hadron scattering
sa mga high energy physics models na maaaring gawin sa pamamagitan ng pag-simulate ng time evolution ng isang hadronic wave packet. Sa kasong ito,
ang isang register ng mga qubit ay maaaring gamitin para i-encode ang iba't ibang mga estado ng isang quantum field. Ang vacuum state ng field na iyon o
isang wave packet na nagpapalawak sa ibabaw ng vacuum na ito.
Ngayon gusto ko ring tandaan na ang pag-map ng problema sa isang quantum computer ay may mga natatanging hakbang na siyang isa ang pag-map ng
mga estado sa mga qubit at circuit at dalawa ang pag-map ng cost function o expectation
ng mga quantum observable at operator. Makikita natin kung paano ito hinahawakan sa mga tiyak na halimbawa. Ngunit sa
puntong ito sapat na nating napag-usapan nang abstract ang hamon na nasa harap natin.
Tingnan na natin ang mga halimbawang ito ngayon nang detalyado.
Magsimula tayo sa ating unang halimbawa. Sa aking palagay, isa sa mga pinakamadaling problema sa mapping ay ang isa na
natalakay na natin nang may kalaliman, ang max cut na halimbawa. Sa problemang iyon, ang mapping ay medyo madali para sa atin dahil ang isang qubit
ay katumbas ng isang node sa aming graph. Ang paggamit ng mga node sa isang graph ay napaka-intuitive at iyon ay
napaka-magaling dahil tumutugma ito sa maraming mga aplikasyon. Maraming beses kapag gusto mong i-model ang isang bagay na tumutugma sa isang
serye ng mga node na nakakonekta nang magkasama, kung ang mga grupo ay binary tulad ng zero o isa o kasama at hindi kasama sa isang
set, madali mo at natural na maaaring i-map ang mga node na ito sa mga bit o qubit.
Sa halimbawang ito, at kahit sa isa na na-scale up natin sa 100 qubit sa episode 3, ang graph connectivity
ay tumugma na sa topology ng aming superconducting hardware. Kaya hindi na natin kailangang mag-alala tungkol doon. Ngayon hindi ito palaging ganoon.
At kung mayroon kang mas kumplikado o konektadong graph kaysa sa mga halimbawang na-highlight natin sa ngayon, pupunta ka
sa kailangang ipatupad ang mga swap gate. Ngunit ito ay aktwal na hinahawakan sa ikalawang hakbang ng Qiskit patterns na nauugnay sa
transpilation. Ang isa pang bahagi ng max cut problem na ginagawa itong napaka-maginhawa ay ang
alam na natin kung paano ipahayag ang cost function bilang isang Hamiltonian gamit ang QUBO formulation.
Alalahanin na sa quantum computing at variational quantum algorithms, ang isang Hamiltonian cost function ay isang function
na nag-e-encode ng optimal na solusyon ng problema sa ground state ng Hamiltonian.
Para itayo ang cost Hamiltonian, nagawa nating gamitin ang sparse Pauli op class sa Qiskit para tukuyin ang
connectivity ng aming graph at ang mapping stage sa mga quantum operator ay tapos na. At ang quantum circuit ay
simpleng ang QAOA ansatz. Ngayon, kung hindi ito tumatawag ng anumang maalala, bumalik at tingnan ang episode 3 kung saan tayo
dumaan dito nang mas detalyado. Ngayon, bahagya nating tataasan ang kahirapan. Susunod, titingnan natin
ang isang halimbawa na na-model sa papel na tinatawag na resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding na isinulat ng
IBM sa pakikipagtulungan sa University of New South Wales. Kaunting background sa biochemistry. Ang mga protina ay
mga macromolecule na binubuo ng mahabang chain ng mga amino acid. Ang mahabang mga chain na ito ay nagtatiklop
sa mga kumplikadong istruktura na gumaganap ng malawak na iba't ibang mga biological function.
Ang pagtukoy ng istruktura ng protina sa isang three-dimensional na espasyo at pag-unawa sa mga relasyon sa pagitan ng
istruktura at function ay kabilang sa mga pinaka-mapaghamong problema sa biochemistry ngayon.
Ang mga protina ay natitiklop sa mga kapaki-pakinabang na istruktura dahil sa mga interaksyon sa pagitan ng mga amino acid mismo.
Habang ang istruktura ay nagtitirante at nagtatiklop, ang mga amino acid na malayo sa isa't isa sa chain ay maaaring magtapos nang malapit sa
isa't isa at maaaring mag-interact nang malakas. Kailangan nating makakuha ng isang Hamiltonian na naglalarawan ng lahat ng mga interaksyon sa pagitan ng amino
acids kung gusto nating hulaan kung aling huling istruktura ang magpapaliit ng enerhiya. Dito ay magtutuon tayo sa mga amino acid chain at
kung paano sila maaaring ma-model sa isang quantum computer at pagkatapos kung paano natin maaaring makuha ang mga inter-amino acid na distansya para sa
pagkalkula ng mga interaction energies.
Sa ito, talagang makakalap na tayo ng lahat ng kinakailangang mga kontribusyon sa Hamiltonian para i-simulate
ito sa isang quantum computer. Sa mga tunay na protina, ang mga amino acid ay maaaring sumaklaw sa isang continuum ng mga posibleng lokasyon.
Gayunpaman, gagamit tayo ng simplipikasyon dito at paghihigpitan ang mga ito sa isang lattice model kung saan ang bawat amino acid
ay sumasaklaw sa isang punto sa isang grid. Dito, ginamit ng mga may-akda ang isang tetrahedral lattice.
Mabilis na tala dito na nag-e-encode tayo ng direksyon ng mga edge at hindi ng mga node mismo tulad ng sa max cut problem.
Ang bawat qubit ay kumakatawan sa isang posibleng single-step na landas kasunod ng tetrahedral grid. Tandaan na ang mga kalapit na site ay
na-label sa diagram na ito bilang A o B dahil sa kanilang iba't ibang oryentasyon sa lattice.
Ang protein chain ay kinakatawan bilang isang serye ng mga turn o direksyon sa
lattice na ito. Ang bawat turn sa pagitan ng mga amino acid ay maaari sa isa sa apat na direksyon
na katumbas ng mga gilid ng tetrahedron.
Ang apat na posibleng turn na ito ay naka-encode gamit ang apat na qubit.
Ito ay parang kaunting mapaghamong. Kaya tingnan ang halimbawang ito nang kaunting mas malalim.
Ilagay natin ang ating unang amino acid chain sa puntong ito sa tetrahedral lattice. Ang direksyon sa unang
amino acid chain patungo sa ikalawa ay arbitrary dahil ang sistema ay palaging maaaring i-rotate para gawing ang edge na ito ay nagtuturo
sa anumang direksyon na gusto natin. Kaya ilagay natin ang ating ikalawang amino acid dito. Hindi ito ganoon
kadaling makita, ngunit ang landas mula sa ikalawa hanggang sa ikatlo ay talagang arbitrary din. Ang lahat ng tatlong pagpipilian ay
magreresulta sa pagkakaroon ng dalawa sa mga gilid na may anggulo na humigit-kumulang 109.5°
sa pagitan nila. Ang pagpili ng ikalawang gilid na ito ay nagtatakda lamang ng oryentasyon ng aming protina sa espasyo. Kaya nang walang pagkawala ng
pangkalahatang katangian, maaari tayong pumili ng mga unang turn na maging 0 0 1 at 0 0 1
0. Sa mga simplipikasyong ito, ang configuration ng amino acid chain ay simpleng ibinibigay ng ekspresyong ito.
Sa ngayon nai-map na natin ang mga tetrahedron edge sa mga qubit at ang aming quantum circuit ay magiging isang ansatz. Ngayon kailangan
nating isaalang-alang kung paano i-encode ang enerhiya ng problema sa isang Hamiltonian para ang ground state nito ay nagbibigay sa atin ng pinakamainam
na folding pattern. Ngayon para sa anumang ibinigay na configuration ay magkakaroon ng kaugnay na enerhiya dahil sa mga
interaksyon sa pagitan ng mga amino acid mismo. Ang mga interaksyong ito ay pinakamatipid kapag ang dalawang amino acid ay
malapit sa isa't isa. Maliwanag ang mga amino acid na katabing katabi sa backbone ng chain ay palaging mag-iinteract sa
isa't isa. Ngunit dahil ang protina ay maaaring magtirante at matiklop, ang iba pang mga pares ng amino acid
ay maaari ring mag-interact. Ang mga amino acid 10 at 20, halimbawa, ay maaaring magtapos na nasa
mga katabing site pagkatapos na matiklop ang protina. Ang mga amino acid na malapit sa isa't isa ay may mas malakas na
interaksyon at nagtutulak sa proseso ng folding, ngunit hindi sila kinakailangang may mga indeks na malapit sa isa't
isa. Kaya kailangan natin ng isang formula para ilarawan ang distansya D sa pagitan ng mga amino acid I at
J gamit ang impormasyon na naka-encode sa mga configuration qubit. Sa ganitong paraan maaari
nating gamitin ang kanilang distansya sa paghihiwalay para matukoy kung gaano kalakas sila nagkikipag-interaksyon. Ito ay kaunting kumplikado
ngunit sumama sa akin dahil ito ay isang magandang trick. Una, ipakilala natin ang isang function f sub a ng i na nagpapahiwatig kung
ang isang gilid a ay ginagamit para sa turn sa amino acid i. Dito ang a ay maaaring kumuha ng anumang
isa sa apat na posibleng direksyon sa liwanag ng configuration coding sa itaas. Maaari nating isulat ang mga function na ito at pagkatapos ay maaari
tayong tukuyin ang isang pagkakaiba sa bilang ng mga turn na may label na a sa A at B lattices mula sa
index I hanggang sa index J bilang delta N. Bakit natin ito gagawin? Kaya, natuklasan na ang
tetrahedral lattice ay may isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na katangian. Magtuon tayo sa amino acid na ito dito. Hindi mahalaga kung aling isa
ito, ngunit tawagin nating ang E amino acid. Gusto nating malaman kung gaano kalayo ang j amino acid. At lahat ng mayroon
tayo ay ang mga gilid kung saan ang backbone ay humakbang. Simula mula sa I tandaan na ang isang hakbang
palabas mula sa sentro kasunod ng isang partikular na uri ng gilid tawagin itong a mula sa a lattice
na site ay eksaktong kabaligtaran at di-ginawa ng isang hakbang palabas kasunod ng gilid a mula sa
b sites. Kaya maraming hakbang kasunod ng gilid A mula sa anumang A lattice site ay nagpalayo sa
backbone mula sa E amino acid at ang mga hakbang kasunod ng uri ng gilid A mula sa B sites ay
nagbabalik sa iyo. Kaya ang distansya sa pagitan ng dalawang amino acid I at J kasunod ng gilid
na uri na ita-label natin A ay nakasalalay sa pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng mga hakbang na ginawa kasunod ng A
mga gilid mula sa A sites at B sites. Dahil ang A at B ay kinakailangang nagpapalit sa
protein backbone, ito ay nakuha ng minus1 sa K na termino. At ang argumentong ito ay naaangkop din sa iba pang mga uri ng gilid
pati na rin. Kaya ang distansya sa pagitan ng mga amino acid sa tetrahedral lattice steps ay maaaring kalkulahin sa huli sa pamamagitan ng
ekspresyon na ito. Ngunit paano tayo makakakuha ng Hamiltonian mula sa mahabang ekwasyong ito para sa kabuuang distansya sa pagitan ng mga amino acid? Mayroon
talagang isang one-to-one na katumbas sa pagitan ng mga distansyang ito sa tetrahedral lattice steps at ng Euclidean
distansya. At makikita mo na kinalkula ko na ang ilan sa mga ekspresyon para sa iyo.
Ang mga distansyang ito ay maaaring gamitin sa pagkalkula ng enerhiya ng iyong configuration.
Depende sa iyong layunin, maaari kang magtakda ng isang cutoff distance kung saan isasaalang-alang mo ang pares na nagkikipag-interaksyon
o maaaring gumawa ka ng mas kumplikadong bagay. Maaaring hindi ito malinaw, ngunit talagang tapos na tayo sa mapping
stage sa paggawa nito. Ang mga estado ng mga qubit ay nagpapahiwatig ng turn, at ang koleksyon ng mga turn ay nagtatakda ng
distansya sa pagitan ng anumang pares ng amino acid. Ang mga pares ng iba't ibang mga species ng amino
acids ay may iba't ibang interaksyon, ang ilan ay attractive, ang ilan ay repulsive. Kung ginagamit mo ang configuration at distansya para
matukoy lamang kung ang mga kilalang interaksyon ng amino acid ay naka-on o off, ang
lakas ng mga ito ay kilala. Hindi ko, ngunit maaari mo itong hanapin sa isang talahanayan dito tulad ng isang ito. Kaya sa buod, sa
halimbawang ito, ang mga qubit ay ginagamit para markahan ang mga lokasyon sa isang lattice na magkasamang bumubuo ng isang chain ng mga amino acid.
At sa pamamagitan ng pag-simulate kung paano sila nagtitiklop, maaari tayong makahanap ng mas magandang mga resulta sa medikal na pananaliksik. Ngayon,
laktawan namin kung paano kalkulahin ang ilang mga termino ng Hamiltonian na ito dahil ang mga ito ay napaka-tiyak sa problemang ito. Habang ang pagtukoy
ng mga direksyon sa isang lattice ay maaaring ilapat nang mas pangkalahatan.
Kapag mayroon ka nang isang pangkalahatang Hamiltonian, palagi mong gugustuhing isalain iyon sa mga Pauli operator na
native sa quantum computer. Iyon ang tatalakayin natin susunod.
Magpatuloy tayo. Ngayon tuklasin natin kung paano isalin ang isang sistema ng mga subatomic particle sa mga Pauli operator. Ang mga subatomic
particle ay nahahati sa dalawang kategorya. Mga boson at fermion. Ang mga boson
tulad ng mga photon o ang Higgs boson ay sumusunod sa isang tiyak na hanay ng mga statistical na tuntunin at ang mga fermion tulad ng mga elektron o neutrino ay sumusunod ng isa pa.
Ang pangunahing pagkakaiba sa pagitan nila ay ang mga boson ay pinapayagang sumasaklaw sa parehong estado. Walang limitasyon kung gaano karaming
mga boson ang maaari sa ground state o anumang iba pang excited state. Ang mga fermion sa kabilang banda ay makasarili. Hinihiling nila na
ang bawat solong particle ay may sariling quantum state. Ang mga boson ay mayroon ding integer spins habang ang mga fermion ay may half integer
spins tulad ng spin 1/2 na elektron o mas exotic na spin tatlong kalahati na mga particle. Para
ilarawan ang isang sistema ng mga particle, kailangan natin ng isang paglalarawan ng kanilang enerhiya. Magtuon tayo sa mga fermion. Maaari tayong magsimula sa
Hamiltonian na nasusulat sa mga tuntunin ng tinatawag nating mga C operator. Ang mga ito ay karaniwang mga mathematical object na
tumutugma sa paglikha o pag-annihilate ng isang fermion mula sa isang estado sa sistema.
Ang mga ito ay madalas na isinulat bilang fi dagger at fi at isang notasyong tinatawag nating ikalawang
quantization. Ngayon ang fi dagger ay ang operator na lumilikha ng isang fermion sa estado i. Ang fi ay
ang operator na nagsisira ng isang fermion sa estado i. Ngunit tandaan na ang mga quantum computer ay karaniwang gumagana sa isang qubit
basis na may mga tiyak na panuntunan para sa pagrepresenta ng mga fermionic na sistema. Hindi sila likas na gumagana sa wika ng
mga fermionic operator. Para tulayin ang agwat na ito, kailangan nating i-map ang ikalawang quantized na notasyon sa mga Pauli operator na
natural na tumutugma sa mga quantum gate.
Mayroon ilang mga ganitong transformation para sa mga fermion. Ang isang karaniwang pagpipilian ay ang Jordan-Wigner transformation.
Ang Bravyi-Kitaev at parity mappings ay mas kamakailang para sa mga fermionic encoding.
Ang mga bosonic operation sa kabilang banda ay maaaring baguhin sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng Holstein-Primakoff transformation o direkta
na pag-map ng mga Fock state sa isang subbasis ng mga available na bosonic mode.
At mayroon ding iba pang mga pagpipilian para sa mga boson. Ang iba pang mga encoding ay aktibo rin na pinananaliksikan. Ngunit sa ngayon,
magtutuon lang tayo sa Jordan-Wigner transform.
Kaya bakit hindi natin itakda ang isang qubit para kumatawan ng bawat elektron? Kaya, hindi tayo maaari.
Ang mga qubit ay nakikilala at ang mga elektron ay hindi. Halimbawa, madali tayong makapag-label at matukoy ang mga indibidwal na qubit sa
anumang device, ngunit ang hindi-pagkakilanlan ng mga elektron ay nangangahulugang hindi natin sila ma-label sa lahat. kailangan nating aktwal na i-label
sa halip ang mga operator ayon sa mga occupied orbital tulad ng 1s 2s at 2p
sa halip na mga tiyak na elektron. Kaya kailangan nating aktwal na i-label ang mga operator ayon sa mga occupied orbital tulad ng 1s
2s at 2p sa halip na mag-label ng mga tiyak na elektron. Kaya ang bawat qubit ay gumaganap ng
humigit-kumulang ang papel ng isang orbital sa molekula na alinman ay occupied o unoccupied.
Ngunit kung paano natin ito gagawin ay talagang kaunting mas kumplikado. Kaya ngayon ipinakilala namin ang tinatawag na Jordan-Wigner mapping para subaybayan ang
anti-symmetry at matiyak na ang tamang statistics ng kabuuang fermionic system ay sinusunod. Ang Jordan-
Wigner mapping ay conceptually simple dahil sa one-to-one na ugnayan sa pagitan ng mga orbital at qubit. Mayroon
iba pang mga mapping na nagkakamit ng katulad na layunin kasama na ang parity mapping.
Ang pagkalkula ng parity ng isang estado ay nangangailangan ng pagsasaalang-alang ng maraming qubit. Sa parity mapping at iba pa, ang
interpretasyon ng isang qubit na katumbas ng isang orbital ay hindi inaaplay.
Ngayon ay sama-sama nating lakad ang isang medyo simpleng halimbawa para matiyak na mayroon tayong kaalaman ng transformation na ito.
Sabihin nating gusto nating kalkulahin ang single qubit interaction f dagger f. Magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagsingit ng ating mga kahulugan para sa
raising at lowering operator. Pagkatapos ay maaari tayong mag-group ng mga termino na factoring out ang identity matrix i at ang 1/4.
Tulad ng nakikita natin, nananatili tayong may mga termino na magiging pamilyar sa mga nakikitungo sa commutation relations. Ang terminong ito dito sa
panaklong ay wala kundi ang i * ang commutator ng x knot at y. At huwag
kalimutang ang identity na kinuha natin.
Ngayon tandaan na ang mga ito ay mga Pauli matrix lamang. Kaya ang commutator ay kilala na. Ang commutator ng x at y sa
pagkakasunod na iyon ay simple. Ito ay 2 i z. Siguraduhing huwag mawala ang track ng iyong mga negatibong tanda at makukuha mo ito bilang iyong huling
resulta. Sa huli, matagumpay nating muling isinulat ang isang fermionic expression sa
mga tuntunin ng mga Pauli operator na mauunawaan ng aming quantum computer.
Mabilis nating talakayin kung paano natin ipapatupad ang Jordan-Wigner mapping sa Qiskit dahil bagaman sa tingin ko ito ay
mahalaga na maunawaan kung paano gumagana ang mapping at mga katulad na transformation at makita ito na naitrabaho man lang nang isang beses, hindi mo
gugustuhing manu-manong gawin ang lahat ng trabahong ito sa bawat pagkakataon.
Lalo na para sa malalaking sistema, maaari tayong gumamit ng sparse Pauli op function sa Qiskit para
madaling likhain ang mga kaugnay na Pauli operation mula sa isang mapping. Ang isang hindi optimal na
implementasyon ay gagamit ng mga nested loop at tumatagal ng humigit-kumulang 20 linya ng code.
Ililista ko ang code dito para tuklasin ng lahat. Ngunit sa mataas na antas, ang mga hakbang ay ang mga sumusunod.
Isa, gamitin ang sparse Pauli ops from list function para lumikha ng isang identity operator
na katumbas ng sukat ng parameter space na imi-map. Dalawa, sumusunod sa kahulugan ng creation
at annihilation operator na ipinapakita nang dati, gamitin ang sparse Pauli ops from list function para tukuyin ang x, y, at z Pauli
operation. Magma-map ito ng mga fermionic creation at annihilation operator sa qubit spin operators na nag-e-encode ng fermionic
occupation number sa computational basis ng mga qubit at tatlo ay bumuo ng nais na
Hamiltonian sa Pauli basis sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng mga operator sa itaas sa mga orbital ng interes. Karaniwang tumutugma ito sa
paglikha ng isang identity matrix na kumakatawan sa core ng mga non-interacting orbital at pagkatapos ay pag-apply ng creation
at annihilation operator sa active space na may mga timbang na katumbas ng mga tiyak ng problema. Tulad ng
nabanggit ko, ito ay isang mataas na antas na breakdown lamang. Ang code ay hindi masyadong kumplikado bagaman, at dapat kang
makaramdam ng kumpiyansa sa pag-angkop nito sa iba pang mga problema ng interes.
Ngayon na lubos na natin naiintindihan ang Jordan-Wigner mapping scheme, tingnan natin ito sa aksyon sa isang mas kumplikadong setup.
Maaaring matandaan mo ang papel na ito mula sa isang nakaraang episode din tungkol sa hadron dynamics. Hindi ko na muling tatalakayin ang papel nang malalim, ngunit pakitingnan
ang nakaraang episode kung nalampasan mo ito at curious ka. Sa halimbawang ito, ang Jordan-Wigner mapping ay ginagamit para
ipahayag ang Hamiltonian ng lattice sites na may L sites para sa Schwinger model sa kawalan ng isang electric field. Dito,
mas mahirap na tiyak na tukuyin kung ano ang kumakatawan ng isang qubit sa modelong ito dahil ito ay ang
koleksyon ng mga qubit nang magkasama na bumubuo ng isang pisikal na bagay. Sa kontekstong ito, isang wave packet. Sa halip, maaari mo
humigit-kumulang isipin ang mga qubit bilang mga discretized na piraso ng espasyo kung saan dito ang L ay ang lattice volume kung saan ang bawat elemento o
unit cell ay binubuo ng dalawang qubit. Ang mga fermionic operator na nakita natin sa nakaraang slide ay naglalarawan ng amplitude ng
wave function sa isang partikular na site.
Kaya ang aming Hamiltonian ay naglalaman ng mga fermionic raising at lowering operator. Ngunit para ipatupad ang ganyang
Hamiltonian sa isang quantum computer, kailangan nating ipahayag ito sa mga tuntunin ng mga spin operator, hindi ng mga fermionic operator.
Kaya gagamit tayo ng Jordan-Wigner transformation. Pagkatapos ilapat ang Jordan-Wigner transformation, ang aming bagong
Hamiltonian ay nagiging ekwasyong ito sa ibaba ng slide kung saan ang sigma plus ay ang Pauli operator X + I Y at ang sigma
minus ay X - IY. Kapag mayroon na tayong Hamiltonian na nasusulat sa format na ito, ang
mahirap na bahagi ng mapping stage ay tapos na at maaari na itong madaling isulat sa isang circuit sa mga Pauli operator.
Sa buod, tinalakay natin ang apat na halimbawa kung paano ang mga tiyak na teknik ng mapping ay ginamit kamakailan sa
larangan ng quantum computing. Simula sa pinakasimple at patungo sa pag-apply ng Jordan-Wigner transform sa
hadron dynamics. Naiintindihan ko na ito ay maraming bagay. Ang materyal na ito ay napaka-teknikal
at kung hindi mo pa ito nakita dati, maaaring ito ay napaka-nakakatakot. Ang magandang balita ay nangangako ako na nagiging mas madali at
mas pamilyar habang mas maraming oras ang ginugugol mo sa pagsasanay. At iyon talaga ang laro at bakit ko pinangalanan ang buong
serye na Quantum Computing sa Praktika.
Hindi ito isang bagay na maaaring kunin at patakbuhin ng sinuman mula sa simula. Nangangailangan ito ng ilang pag-aaral, ilang
pag-iisip, at malamang na ilang nakakafrustrang oras. Ngunit hinihikayat ko kayong lahat na makiugnay sa kakulangang ginhawa at
tunay na tuklasin ang mga tanong na lumabas habang nagpapatuloy ka dahil ito lang ang tunay na paraan para matuto. Salamat sa
panonood. Ito ay episode 5 ng quantum computing sa praktika. Sa susunod na beses ay tuklasin natin kung paano i-simulate
ang isang Hamiltonian mula sa simula. Magkita-kita tayo.